[Music]
have you spoken to Rachel since filming
ended since even the episode last night
yeah we have we talked back and forth
every once in a while I mean I'm excited
to focus on our friendship now more than
a romantic relationship with her I think
she's an awesome girl so I mean we have
no bad blood whatsoever do you know who
she picks nope
do you have a difference in your mind on
who you think she should pick versus who
you think she will take yes I think that
she'd be incredibly happy with Peter or
an Eric but I think that she is very
much in lust with a Brian right now so I
could see you're making that emotional
decision based off of that I keep seeing
these red flags everywhere with Brian
and yeah it's just it's just I think
just the heart ice on on Rachel are kind
of blinding her a little bit he's
definitely knows how to say the right
things in the right time right Peter and
him didn't necessarily have the best
friendship so with me being good friends
of Peter I kind of had to take his side
and be anti Brian but I mean who are we
to decide whether his intentions are
here or not you know we only really see
a small snippet of everything so so do
you think his intentions affair mmm
we the feather
[Music]